let's go to dan in boise idaho dan
what's going on
hey guys thanks for taking my call i
just got a quick question for you about
a job change
my wife had fantastic what's up
well um she got pushed out of her long
time
stable job under the guise of
reorganization
and so luckily we've done well enough or
financially it's not going to hit us
real hard
and she right away started looking for
new work
and got offered a job and then
she accepted that job and then a week
later she got off a different job that
pays
more than she was making at her old job
and we're just i'm not sure
i don't want to push her in any
direction whatsoever but i just
you know i'm not sure how to handle like
which one should she take you know or
well let's
start with what she wants what does she
want to do right now well
well and i am totally cool with whatever
she wants to do don't get me wrong
um and she wants to um take a step back
you know she had a very
um time intensive job where she worked
60 80 hours a week in certain
certain months of the year and she wants
to
take a step back work part-time which
i'm fine with
and and you know get our benefits that
way and
um i just look into the future you know
i don't want to work forever you know
okay but hold on hold on
i understand what you're telling me but
i'm just simply trying to understand she
just took
one job she's in that job right now she
got offered another job and you're
trying to say
which what which one should she take
i've got an opinion
but it's based on what you tell me and
so i want to know
does she want is she herself right now
leaning towards this new opportunity
that just came along or are you seeing
dollar signs as her husband
and you're trying to go hey let's do
this check out this shiny toy yeah
so where is she where is she she
she wants to follow through with a
part-time job which is totally fine is
that the one she's in right now
that's the one she's in she's she just
did the orientation for today got it so
if she
if she were to take the one that just
got offered that's back into the
full-time deal and she doesn't want to
do that
correct not right now so i think it's
pretty i think i think it's pretty
straightforward if my wife is in this
situation
i know that i probably want the more
money myself but if i'm talking to
stacey and i'm going stace what do you
want to do babe
she's going man you know what i've been
doing this 60 hours every seasonal for
once
you know for a long time and i'd like to
just start to step back
i got a good part-time job right now
this is what i want and i've got it i
want to stay put
sounds like that's the right decision
yeah and and that's you know that's what
i thought too it's just you know you got
that shiny number out there
that i'm just like well we could really
get ahead
or you know but i understand she wants
to take a step back that's fine
then that's what i got that's what
that's what i would go with
man and i i would how long you been
married
13 years 13 years um let me ask
something john i'm sorry to interrupt
but but i want to make sure
i didn't ask you this uh dan yeah what
does get ahead mean is that payoff debt
or is it just savings in retirement what
does that
mean get ahead it's a it's a little bit
of both
you know i i've been listening to the
program for a while and i really want to
get
debt free and we have been working
towards that goal
but she has her idea of the way she
wants to do it and i have my
you know your guy's idea or dave's idea
oh okay so that's what i was making
a little different you guys have there's
something else going on here man
um
the question you asked is not the
question you should have asked yeah what
tell us what's going on in your marriage
man it sounds like there's a
a a fracture there well i wouldn't say
it's a fracture i just
it's hard for me to i don't know if it's
um
you know just explain how this would all
work out if we just went
this direction versus what she wants to
she's a favor
and we have quite a bit in savings we
probably have enough in savings to pay
off the debt that we
that i want to pay off right but she
doesn't want to go down
you know she doesn't want to get rid of
that safety net and
which i get how much debt do you have
but
um total we have about i'd say
45. how much do you have in savings
we uh well okay the debt that i wanted
to pay off so we have about
25 in savings what do you mean the debt
you want to pay off
there's some debt you just like to hold
on to for a long time because you got a
great relationship with it no no you
realize what show you
clarify here yeah please don't i know i
know
i know stupid question um
so i have a student loan that i
refinance and i want to get rid of that
and we have a heloc that we're done with
that we that i want to pay off because
that has a chance for the rate to change
okay what's your total debt give me stop
giving me
all the conditions what's your total
debt debt you want in debt you don't
want 45.
okay so you get you did give me the
whole number okay and then you have 25
in savings
okay how big of a hit did she take just
give me a ballpark idea how much she
how much of a hit she took financially
by going from uh full time to part time
oh she probably she's probably gonna
make a third of what she would
okay why is she why is she fried man
um part of it was the atmosphere that
she was in
uh very male dominated kind of
you know toxic you know that kind of
deal and it just
the the place where she was working for
23 years it started out as a family
situation and now it's just gone
straight corporate
you know very different atmosphere and
she's just kind of
done with that whole you know that whole
organization so when you say hey dan
when you sit down
and talk to her and say hey we've got
this 45
000 bucks there's a proven plan six
million people
what is her response what is it about
the way you present this that makes her
think i'm out
um she just wants to have the money in
savings in case something happens
and i and i've framed it like well
something can happen all the time
right that doesn't really matter so you
know here's what i'm going to tell you
when you called the show you talked
about
you don't want to have to work forever
you talked about
yeah you don't want to her to turn this
money down
you want two guys on the radio to tell
your wife what she should be doing
you want to pay off your student loan
and so here's what i want to challenge
you with
you gave me a lot of what you want to do
and with within three or four minutes
it sounds like your wife has come from a
very
toxic to use your words male dominated
world didn't listen to her that was
telling her what to do
and i'm wondering if she's getting that
from you too and i'd love to see you sit
down and say
not hey you know what we could be doing
because what you're doing there is
giving information
you're giving an answer to a question
she really hasn't even asked yet right
and right now she's defaulting to safety
i want you to sit down and say not that
kind of that conversation but
what do we want to do two years three
years
five years you're fried i love the fact
that you
found this cool opportunity it's gonna
cost us a lot of money to us
not you not me but us what do we want to
do and where we want to move
towards what do we want to move forward
towards and i want you to give her an
environment where she can
dream openly because my guess is you
love her so much that you want to give
her the right information and a lot of
times
we can drown our the people that we love
with the right answers and more
information
and really they just want to be heard
they just want to know that things are
safe
and so they default to savings accounts
or jobs or other things to try to grab
safety
i want you to reach out and connect with
her